sri lanka is facing its most serious
economic and political crisis in decades
with protests on the streets and
officials resigning and being replaced
so quickly we're not sure how long the
next finance minister will stick around
because the new appointee lasted just a
day
people are struggling to get the basics
from food to fuel some observers say the
poorest may soon face starvation
years of government mismanagement and
corruption compounded by the pandemic
has led to this tragedy
troops patrol the streets outside the
parliament in colombo locked down after
unprecedented street demonstrations
against sri lanka's president gotobaya
rajapaksa
once wildly popular his approval ratings
have been undermined by people's anger
at rampant inflation as well as food
fuel and medicine shortages
the coveted pandemic destroyed sri
lanka's tourism industry leading to a
lack of foreign exchange for imports
i started a small business recently
but it's very difficult to maintain it
there's no gas there's no kerosene
that's why people are protesting in the
streets
[Music]
people are suffering a lot they've
reached the end of their patients
one can't say how the people will behave
what decision they'll take
gotobaya rajapaksa is backed by sri
lanka's powerful sinhala buddhist
majority who credit him with ending the
26-year long civil war in 2009
the protests threaten one of the most
powerful asian political dynasties
in 2020 mahinda rajapaksa won elections
to become sri lanka's prime minister
serving under his brother and president
gotabaya
in 2021 another sibling basil was named
finance minister tightening the family's
grip on power
demonstrators accused the president of
mismanaging sri lanka's most painful
downturn since independence from britain
in 1948.
the protests began last month but have
intensified in the past few days
leading to clashes between protesters
and police in some instances
so we are here behalf of sri lanka the
entire nation so we are facing so many
crises we have no money people are
struggling people have no food people
have nothing people have no gas to cook
people have no money to fight
revoked a state of emergency after
dozens of lawmakers walked out of the
ruling coalition
but the troops remain on the streets
there is no certain way out of sri
lanka's worst political crisis for
decades
joining us from colombo is ambaka sakuna
nathan human rights advocate and
formerly with the human rights
commission of sri lanka thanks for
joining the program ambaka what's
happening in sri lanka has been a long
time coming i want to start with the
economy
tell us a bit more about how the country
ended up where it is today
yes as you would have seen right now
we're facing a foreign exchange crisis
uh due to which we also are facing um
shortage of fuel
gas
um which is affecting uh
even the large industries small and
medium industries and just generally um
economic activity uh we are unable to
therefore meet uh also debt repayments
which means that we can possibly default
which then uh as someone said it's worse
than even uh internal armed conflict
that we faced and this has been a long
time coming because it is part economic
crisis and part political crisis and the
economic crisis brought on by years of
mismanagement of also this particular
government despite the fact that it was
advised to go to the international
monetary fund by many experts refused to
do that and that i think was also part
of their campaign slogans and what they
uh campaigned to come into power which
is that we will not uh seek external
help we will safeguard
sovereignty they also appointed someone
to the central bank who uh economic
experts clearly say was not qualified to
um
to make these decisions or to advise the
government on these decisions which is
why right now we're at a point where
there is an economic meltdown and a
political crisis which is having a
severe impact on the socio-economic uh
you know status of so many people from
school children to daily wage earners to
um uh the
free trade zone workers who worked in
the factories um it is having an adverse
impact i would say on practically well
nearly all segments of society
now more than 40 members of the
legislature left the governing coalition
this week so now you have a minority
group running the country how much is
the country
you know with the legislature a
democracy as opposed to the rajapaksa
family having most of the power
well even now the problem that we have
is many of the people who are part of
the governing coalition have said that
they have left the governing coalition
and that they are going to function in
parliament as independents
but we still don't know whether when it
comes to certain issues that they would
want with the government in which case
probably why that is why the opposition
is also afraid to test it with a no
confidence motion and the opposition is
also playing what it seems a waiting
game for instance yesterday they made a
decision that today and tomorrow they
would be debating this in parliament
whereas the economic crisis at a point
you know it's going to be meltdown and
in a month or two there will be severe
crisis um
and all economic activity can possibly
shut down uh but yet i think even the
opposition is not putting forward a plan
they are not uh
testing or they are being reluctant to
take responsibility so what is being
proposed is also a caretaker government
but that also brings into play uh many
constitutional questions the question
you asked about you know democracy the
fact is this was in a sense electoral
democracy i would say i mean it is but
it's also electoral authoritarianism in
that through election someone is
governed but that regime is
authoritarian and it also functions a
more it's a family and it functions
through dispensing patronage
so
not ideal
what comes next
what comes next is that today in
parliament uh one of the cabinet mps you
would have known that all the mps uh
resigned
and they reappointed some of them the
minister of foreign affairs minister of
finance and ministry of highways a
question that you might ask is why do
you need a minister of highways at this
time and perhaps not for instance a
minister of health
um and uh so the minister uh
mentioned in parliament that the
president sees absolutely no reason to
resign uh the protest as you would have
seen are calling for his resignation and
the protests are getting larger the
crowd is getting angrier because every
day they are faced with more shortages
um diminishing incomes for some of them
it's complete lack of income and uh
being able to only eat one knee a day so
if we do not see the president stepping
down that does bring us to an impasse
because you could possibly impeach the
president but once again that's a
lengthy process a procedure for which we
really do not have time and while the
president and the prime minister
and it's not a very ideal situation that
we're facing and something that we'll
have to get back to you on over the next
few weeks
thank you so much for joining us
thank you
you